you worked the case and hey if you guys
need any pointers on a cool high five or
something i could
well if you need suggestions let me know
amy since you're last year's champion
you go first
i choose rosa dope so i believe the key
to good teamwork is an equal exchange of
ideas stop
i know you already have a plan and i
want to win so for the next eight hours
i'm down with all your nerdy crap come
on amy
show me the binder okay but it's not a
binder
it's a virtual binder and it's encrypted
on this flash drive
that's my girl now where's the 3d model
of the precinct
inside the keychain it's a freaking
hologram
yes i have eyes on christy stacy and
claudia you used your code names
you read the plans addenda and all damn
right i did i told you
i'm all in and you didn't make fun of me
for basing it all on the babysitter's
club and i even did your suggested
reading of christy's big day
you did calm down you're such a marianne
i am it's true all i have to say is
whoever took that plaque you better
watch out
come on rosa
[Music]
come on boyle yes sir
[Music]
come on bill
okay was the operation a success
you tell me blended right in with the
pizza guys
got all my bowl cutters luck snapped on
the first try
no one saw me leave gotta hand it to you
beautiful plan
beautiful execution it's kind of like
we're our own babysitter's club oh my
god i don't want tonight to ever end
did you by chance read the excerpt from
the truth about stacy the one about the
rival babysitters that get caught
smoking cigarettes
well let's just say that these two
babysitters aren't getting caught with
squat this is where i stash a few
cigarettes
on the rare occasion that i need a puff
dope hiding place not the smoking
marianne is better than that she's a
work in progress
ah there you are i got something real
special for the two of you
great what do you got i'm one from today
it's my birthday i need you to throw me
a party
all right make it epic surprise me are
you asking us to plan you a birthday
party yeah helen killer
pay attention did you choose us because
we're women women love planning parties
that's in the bible unbelievable
what a waste of time disagree this is an
amazing use of time
we have complete control over that
dummy's birthday party we can ruin it
yeah fun i'll just mess up a captain's
orders on purpose
it'll be so i can't even fake it let's
see what you got for the big bday bash
i thought you wanted us to surprise you
it's a figure of speech detective
stupidago
well i was thinking a dj two signature
cocktails a
orders whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
past hors d'oeuvres was a fundraiser for
french dorks
so no password nerves i can't even
answer that
all right tough guy what do you got
planned i don't know
meet at a bar and
drink there that's it but still better
than santiago's
look this is real important to me all
right my brother's a hot wife is gonna
be there and i haven't seen her since
his funeral
wow yeah right i mean you only get one
shot at your brother's widow
just go oh
oh my god you friended the vulture well
he's not telling us anything so is the
only way to figure out what he likes
maybe this will help he just said his
favorite color is underboob
look amy you're a good detective you
don't have to perfectly plan some
butthead's birthday party
i'm sorry but i believe that hard work
pays off
shut up excuse me no no shut up and look
you're completely right your hard work
just paid off
the vulture's in a band fantastic jack
and the junkyard rats
just when i thought he couldn't be
anymore the worst he outbursts himself
i have an idea hey turn monkeys it's
time to celebrate
me let's rock
[Applause]
his tearaway pants just got stuck hiring
him to play his own party was straight
up brilliant
yep because everything he does is a
prank on himself
wow you are an evil genius next time i
want to hurt someone i'm coming straight
to you
oh that's the nicest thing you've ever
said to me
i said who's that mama looking so cool
i'm that mama looking so cool whoa what
oh sorry i didn't see you there yeah
that was clear what's going on why are
you dork dancing a baby store in dumbo
is having a contest to win
a snoog or what is a snoog are you
kidding me
it's only the best roller it has the
versatility of a sports jewel the safety
rating of a forger
and an even smoother ride than the
kinder pushed having a stroke all the
best strollers are from scandinavia
where they don't hate people for having
children i saw midsummer those people
have their own problems the snoog is my
dream stroller but it's way too
expensive
what's a contest it's an endurance
competition everyone has to stand with
one hand on the stroller and if you let
go you're out
last person holding on wins sounds
painful can i come huh
for moral support sure that
i'll compete for her what you will but i
know you think these strollers are dumb
they are but i can't let that boring
bastard win so we decided to paint the
baby room
white i mean you used to have sex with
him i know
rosa i can't believe you're still here i
can't believe teddy looks so normal i'm
gonna win you that snoop
slog snap whatever my brain is broken i
haven't slept in 72 hours you've only
been doing the competition for one night
i mean you're allowed to not sleep for
other reasons
okay i got you a coffee oh thank you
just need to put my left hand on the
stroller
my right hand grabs the cup my mouth
dude is sipping what's happening
my broken brain won't talk to my body so
i'm doing it bling
rosa you don't have to do this you can
stop snarling amy
teddy and i are the only ones left i'm
gonna win this no matter how much he
talks about light rail systems ooh
you should ride the one in akron by the
way very little noise oh my god
enough about light rails let's talk
trams amusement parks
more cities adopted the music park
method oh put your hands on your ears
i just feel like you're having fun hands
are off we have a winner
me i'm on the stroller hey so
given the fact that you haven't slept in
forever i feel like i should drive you
home
i'm not going home i'm going out what
really what is your life
it's pretty good actually oh by the way
i'm sorry that i didn't win you that
stroll
no no you were right i don't need a
snoop it's way too fancy
it is stupid it's not stupid i said you
didn't need it because i already bought
you a stroller for your shower this
weekend it's just
isn't as fancy and i felt bad rosa i
would love any stroller you got me
because it came from you
it's a lift roller oh
that is that is a great stroller i got
you a gift received thank you so much
so i can spare four uniformed officers
to do hourly pass-bys at the bodegas
south of fourth and i'll coordinate with
the um
hourly pass-bys of the wait what was
that that was me talking about hourly
pass-bys oh yeah i heard about the
hourly pass-bys
twice i meant that subtle side look
there was no subtle side look you're
right because it wasn't subtle it was an
unsubtle side look at that dress in the
shop
why are you being such a nut job about
looking for a wedding dress because
being a female sergeant is difficult i
have to work twice as hard to gain my
officers respect and
looking at girly dresses isn't going to
help plus it's a new job and i need to
make it a priority dude i get that but
if you want a beautiful wedding dress
you deserve to find one
look there are no cops around nobody's
gonna see you why don't we just take our
break now
try one on okay okay okay okay
okay okay hell yeah
they are closed we will come back later
yeah
so what do you think i don't love the
sash
but it's fine i'm just gonna get it what
that's the first one you tried on
i once saw you look at 54 different
accordion folders and not buy
any of them due to weak tabs i file hard
i need strong
tabs i just don't want to take up any
more time your break's not even a
quarter done
i'll stay another 10 minutes you'll stay
until i dismiss you irene
music now spin
all units attempt at 10 30 charlie
bodega on smith
purpose heading east on baltic it's us
we're on baltic
oh crap that was him
[Music]
stay down damn sarge maybe i do like the
sash
there's ezra hey you have a minute i'm
actually kind of busy right now
right harboring a fugitive should i come
back he's hearing on the move
gotcha all right sergio
we've been waiting seven years to say
this sergio mindar you're under arrest
that's why i own you apostrophe re can't
believe you caught me
we'll believe it we're an amazing team
we're the sleuth sisters
damn straight we are
lame stay out of sergio
you